- I think the
world lacks optimism.
I think, you know,
everyone's like your energy,
your energy.
I've come to realize
it's just optimism.
Just happy, just positive.
Is what it is.
Just, like, whatever chemicals
are in my body that just allow
me to see the bright side.
And I just don't think
I've realized how
few people have that.
Very few people have
it as black and white,
hundred-zero, I just
think everything is good but,
you know, I'm dying to know out
of 8 billion people like
what the breakdown is.
My gut is like 6 billion just
go directly into having more
pessimism and cynicism and
negativity like 51-49 minimally
all the way down to
very scary places.
I just don't think
there's a lot of 80% optimism.
- [DRock] Is that the
way they're raised or...?
- Just environment,
raised, just all that stuff.
It doesn't come
naturally to a lot of people.
I think that's like, you know,
if I was ever to say I'm lucky
about something, forget
about the business results,
it's lucky that that
optimism comes naturally to me.
I'm just optimistic.
I just think that so much
works for me because I refuse to
accept the negative.
And I don't think, I hate when
people say it's an option
or it's a choice.
I agree with you, Susan.
I don't think it comes
natural to everybody.
I think we are just starting
on the early stages of really
looking at mental
health, the brain,
meditation and I do think
that's like saying be beautiful.
Doesn't come
natural to everybody.
Some of us, you know, yes.
I'm just kidding.
But you know, I, you know,
I do think that
some of some things
are etched with us early
on and I'm so grateful.
I sit here in front of the
2.000 of you which in itself is
ridiculous like I can turn
something on in three minutes
have 2,000 people care enough
to hear what I have to say.
I sit here with
ego and humility,
gratitude and focus,
appreciation and sense of
responsibility all built
around really this optimistic
foundation that is the fuel
that drives me to my hustle
and to my execution
in the marketplace.